very happy to introduce our next speaker
my colleague Daniel from Marquette
University published quite a bit
including some some things specifically
on the swings he's going to be talking
about Cartesian stones as well let me
tell you exactly what that means but
I'll tell you that I'm a fan of
Descartes I've got a few myself
so we've had that chance that you
Sheehan about are interesting very
interesting speaker so I'm just going to
turn it over to you and let you get
underway make sure you can hear me I
guess not
so first of all I want to do this
together and also to the benefactor
really for making such a valuable
contribution to the City of Milwaukee
intellectual cultural contribution also
just to the other speakers those are
some tough accident I'm excited to be
part of this look forward to what's
coming in the rest of the afternoon and
to all of you for being here
you know how we doesn't think this come
together talk about so today's talk
Fermi is Cartesian stoicism : stoicism
for the modern age
so just to decipher the total the title
of there
by Cartesian it just means philosophy
and the tradition of Descartes and
modern age is a bit of a play on words
so like Greg was saying at the beginning
of the warning that in philosophy modern
usually refers to the span of philosophy
from the 17th to the 18th centuries and
so in that case take Harper Lee was
providing stoicism for his day so it is
stoicism for the modern age but also
modern can mean contemporary or recent
and in this sentence Descartes stoicism
provides us for a possible framework for
embracing stoicism and liveth at least
two important present-day developments
the first of today is science and
medicine given what we know about human
anatomy and physiology what does it even
mean for the passions to be a sickness
of the soul the second is just developed
an ethical theory that paid attention to
the importance of care so historically
we've characterized the quality of
emotion its feminine and lesser than the
quality of Reason which historically has
been characterized as masculine and
reason is extremely important but we're
not disembodied minds
part of being human is being social and
we see some of this is what Dan was
talking about with the concentric
circles of care caring for all rational
beings so the car offers us one battle
of how a silic can meet these modern
demands so I'm a historian of philosophy
by training so just a bit of background
to frame our discussion that's ok
Descartes lived in the 17th century he
and I actually share a birthday March
very first it was the 96
that's how I joined my dissertation
topic
[Music]
he died in 1650 and 53 years old and in
a matter of speaking each one of us is a
Cartesian and what I mean by that it was
Dick Hart's brief infectious popularity
throughout Europe the ushered in a new
world of knowledge based on reason and
experience not only on the tradition of
what we believed in the past or
authority of what some like Aristotle
said be using experience and reason to
try to understand the world around us so
after his death his followers began
creating Cartesian text books to replace
the old month that were based on
Aristotle's philosophy trying to sneak
those into the universities and in spite
of some political contention and
religious condemnation x' party chermen
cartesianism quickly became the way that
people did philosophy and science for
about 30 years until newton's principia
became the new standard but if it
weren't for Descartes Neumann may have
just been received as a hot ball
alchemist and so regardless though
either way the world would look
different if it worked for Descartes so
the many people take carts legacy large
Levi's in things besides stoicism so
you've known for his medicine of Dallas
radical doubt it be that we're all
dreaming right now or dreaming that
we're dreaming or maybe you're just
lying on a bed in some laboratory above
Evil Geniuses pumping stoical onto your
brain
relatedly he's known for this cojito
cogito ergo sum I think therefore I am
or maybe a substance dualism that humans
are composed of minds and bodies and
trying to figure out how they interact
we call that the mind-body problem
philosophy even in this day she was
known as a physicist again for 30 years
Cartesian Sizzix was all the rage why am
I talking about
they Kurt stoicism them well towards the
end of his life Descartes began
corresponding with a few people who
became really important to the direction
of his work so the 17th century in the
in the birth still of the Scientific
Revolution journals were something that
had a really a virgin so people have
write each letter each other letters and
distribute them to distribute ideas and
there were two people in particular one
with Pierre Shannon who is the French
ambassador to Sweden and the Dutch
Republic and the other was princess
Elisabeth of Bohemia who was an
aristocrat whose life was kind of awful
she grew up in exile away from her home
her family was kicked out of Bohemia
when she was two she was separated some
free from some priest severe physical
ailments and she becomes an important
correspondent for Descartes and really
it's under the pressure of Princess
Elisabeth to provide more satisfactory
defenses of his ideas that he writes his
final treat his passions of the soul
which was published less than a year
before his death so given the title
passions of the soul that might give a
flavor of the stoicism that's going to
emerge here I'm like it's been already
hinted at already the influence of the
Stoics on modern and by this
I mean 17th and 18th century authors
like Dakar even men will cop maybe come
as a surprise but the early modern
stoves were often settled in their use
of stoicism they would typically
synthesize it with their other
philosophical and theological
commitments to create something uniquely
their own while also unquestionably
stoic as well and that's what we are
going to see with Descartes so leading
up to this time after centuries of being
a token boogey man of the Middle Ages
stoicism begin to reimburse that
subordinate place again a three that
mentioned the Renaissance humanists
shows showed you were you interested in
classical Greek text importantly
including stoicism maybe interestingly
some parallels to houses it was
forgotten in the contemporary world for
a while that's having this we reassert
its resurgence with people bringing into
contemporary discussions changing it to
fit the modern times so this movement is
now referred to as neo stoicism and it
saw itself as interpreting or filling
the role of interpreting festival
stoicism before the new world big Purvis
was exposed to these readings as a youth
and that finally brings us to the
passions of the soul and surrounding
correspondence so if you go out and buy
big hearts passion to the soul expect it
to be something like a treatise on
ethics
you'll probably largely disappointed
because it's really just a treatise on
human physiology and in it he describes
the body is like a pub a machine that's
pumping blood through its veins as the
blood leaves the heart these things
called animal spirits are filtered out
and by the time they reach the brain
they're these little delicate particles
that flow into the course of the brain
and then flow into the nerves and the
nerves are described as these wires with
little fibers in the middle that are
filled with these animal spirits and
really all of our physiological
responses are a result of these animal
spirits and the resulting pressure and
blood temperatures that result from them
so to give an example if you put your
foot
close to a fire the fire's heat causes
motion in the central nerve central
fibers which results in pressure and
movement of the animal spirits within
them and then after the body and my
NanoRacks
a new motion is produced that causes the
opening of the new nerve tubes to expand
and contract admitting more or fewer of
these animal spirits and that it's this
change in motion that causes the muscles
to move in the appropriate area and so
you move your foot away from the fire so
it doesn't get burned so he believes
that this understanding of physiology
explains all of stink chewable reactions
blinking with light as prey it were able
in coals these are all responses of
those animal spirits in the nerves
reacting to external stimuli but this
also explains our passionate emotions he
thinks so he explains hatred this way
you think about something that arouses
aversion these spirits are guided to the
brain or from the brain towards the
stomach rather and towards the
intestinal muscles that keep as a result
it keeps nourishing fluids from weakling
with the blood and this guy's the
spirits towards the spleens nerves
reversing the blow of reversing the flow
of blood in these areas and this causes
inequality it's a blood temperature
since the spleen heats and visit the
blood while the blood coming from the
lower liver expands the blood rapidly as
we all know the mom because of this the
spirits going into the brain he would
say also
[Music]
so where we left off I'm just describing
some examples from Descartes stuff in
theology and the passions of the soul
talking about how hatred is the result
of spirits going into the brain and
there's they're unequal and pressure and
heat and so they cause us to feel angry
he also talks about similar things like
for example with Joyce so the we
experience joy when the openings to the
heart are open wider than usual and so
the spirits flow in abundance to our
brain and that deprives the brain of bad
blood that comes from the spleen and
liver intestines and stomach so we are
filled with joy so I stake artists
developing this physiology he's also
corresponding with Elizabeth we're
calling it a big reason why he's even
developing the physiology is in response
to her and she's struggling just having
a hard time in exile she's been
suffering from her her illness she's
having a pretty hard time at it and you
didn't know this car can be a bit of a
jerk sometimes there's this presumably
friend of his by this point who's
suffering quite a bit and he's just
really dismissive of her at first he
just says yeah yeah you're suffering go
read Seneca Seneca knows all about the
good life and then Descartes clearly
haven't read Seneca and like a decade I
could totally relate some student will
come up with a question like oh yeah I
go read I don't know because whatever of
things and then they come to me in
questions and I realize I've heard that
in a decade maybe they should brush up
on it so take heart
Ricki somewhat regrets having told her
to read Seneca because he wasn't up to
speed to answer her questions but once
he dusted off his copy of Seneca and
started rereading it
he believed that Seneca was generally
writing but he had some problems with
him too
some of those were not too concerned
with right now they were more
theological so you don't want to say
that God in nature art industry
indistinguishable in the 17th
it was another hospital another another
early modern philosopher named Spinoza
who did that and his treatise would be
described as some book forged in hell so
nonetheless he had some in spite of his
concerns gets far more crates for Seneca
than criticisms and part of that is
really Dakar always had instead Thoth a
stoic tendency in his work so for
example in the introduction to his first
publication discourse on method he gives
a temporary morality tears of morality
we can live by until I've taken the time
to elaborate on a more substantive
morality and it's a simple morality but
amongst the moral Maxim's there's a
story so in virtue of constancy for
instance and his letters throughout his
life really mirror stoic undertones that
seems like this is how he was choosing
to to live in spite of not having a
full-blown theory of it yet so and one
of his letters to his friend Bruce on he
defends the virtue of resolved lake wise
Descartes writes to the Dutch scientists
Hawaiians and twentieths that recently
lost his wife he was madly in love with
her he has a heartbreaking poetry that
he wrote on occasion of her death about
the Stars being extinguished from the
sky date our dakar offers some
insensitive but well intended advice
descartes tells him be content that he
was able to care for her while she was
alive and she was able to enjoy her then
but now that she has died he should be
content with the tiresome duty of caring
for her being complete and that he can
no longer have to worry whether or not
she will get well then this of course
murdered Mira's Epictetus this handbook
almost exactly right so epictetus writes
you are foolish if you want your
children your wife and your friends to
live forever since you are wanting
things to be up to you that are not up
to you and things to be yours that are
not yours but wanting not to fail to get
what
desire this is what you are capable of
the person's master is someone who has
power over what he wants or does not
want either to obtain it or to take it
away whoever wants to be free therefore
let him not want or avoid anything that
is up to others so these are just two
examples but thorough expressions of
socialism not a theory of Stoicism right
and both are important stoicism is a
philosophy that's meant to be lived no
it couldn't have been command better to
have a fire alarm in the middle of
stowing hot I think there should be a
regular part of the futures no a con X's
but so when he returns to Seneca in
writing to Elizabeth he begins to
formulate this as a theory these
expressions into something more concrete
so he believes like Seneca happiness and
spouts in the contentment of the mind
and that's the best secure for
misfortunes reason he recommends that
Elizabeth partially treat her physical
maladies by adjusting her dispositions
to them so maybe she might not be able
to heal herself like she can't find
tranquility by recognizing that the good
can arise from the misfortune and it
creates opportunity to know oneself
better he writes to her for example
quote I have since given some thought to
this and find it now sufficiently
rigorous to deserve to be followed
Seneca should have taught us all the
principle truths whose knowledge is
necessary to facilitate the practice of
virtue and to regulate our desires and
passions and thus to enjoy natural
happiness so he finds or if he continues
that that would have made his book the
finest the most useful that a pagan
philosopher would have Brennan and I
just for the sake of time I'm just
taking a snippet of this quote but what
he's painting is he thought he knew
Senecas picture virtue regulating the
passions he thinks the Seneca gets it
almost entirely right but he fails to
provide adequately in a sufficient code
of how to accomplish this and what this
might look like and then contemporary
scientific developments so he breaks to
Elizabeth again in general the soul is
pleased to feel passions arise in itself
no matter what they are provided it
remains in control of them so
in spite of high praise given Cartesian
Cartesian physiology of modern
physiology where the passions really
just are your body functioning as it
functions Descartes believes that the
classical stomachs come up short
describing what the passions are and
more importantly what to do without them
so for Descartes the passions are needed
to inform the soul of what is good and
harmful to the body and they should only
be resistant when a passion runs counter
to an already established firm judgment
in the soul additionally if they are
merely physical physiological that
happiness and virtue should in fact be
pleasurable
he tells Elizabeth that someone with
more exterior Goods made me happier than
someone who does not have good fortune
desire is not antithetical to happiness
and virtue it's easy because it's not
against pleasure so although Descartes
is questioning some Aristotelian
assumptions that material goods health
and comforts are necessary for the good
life he acknowledges that someone with
more exterior goods may have an easier
time may have a better chance of
happiness than someone who does not have
them and that's in contrast with the
classical stoic reading which was
traditionally that Stoics believed that
the body is at best instrumentally good
we're clothing really the body just
clothing for the soul where true virtue
lies but more in line with traditional
is stoicism Descartes describes
contentment in terms of filling a vessel
so if you have external goods that
allows you to have a large vessel that
you still need virtue to fill up but if
you don't have the external goods health
their money friendships or etc you can
still fill those smaller vessels with
contentment
so tranquility then is obtainable
without external goods though perhaps to
a lesser degree the overall satisfaction
so this is an interesting move for
Descartes because it's not only moving
away from Aristotle in important ways
but it also introduces enough another
novelty against classical Stoics
adjusting that virtue can come in
degrees so Descartes argues that an
error that Xena made was making the
supreme good on the intellectual
detached from the body and doing so thus
so to make virtue in teams that have the
ethical to pleasure so to some eyes up
to this point Descartes argues that the
best life will have a book fortune
meaning external goods such as health
and material comforts and contentment
but rejects the notion good fortune is a
necessary condition for contentment and
so we see this in the passions of the
soul or Descartes describes the passions
is not always harmful in fact given his
view that human bodies are just machines
filled with spirits and fibers and tubes
and blood they cannot be intrinsically
bad it's just our body physiologically
reacting to external symchay
so passions are symptoms of physiology
with no initial - were nothing initially
good or bad said about them and so he
simplifies this and passions of the soul
where he writes now that we are
acquainted with all the passions we have
much less reason for anxiety about them
than we have before for we see that they
are all good by nature and that we have
nothing to avoid that their misuse or
access except which the remedies I have
explained might be sufficient in each
person to care is enough took care
enough to apply them so similar to the
classical Stoics Descartes believed that
our first defense from bad passions is
reason we can through practice train
ourselves to regulate our passions but
even with practice passions are
ultimately physiological responses and
sometimes we can't just think them away
he says our passions too cannot be
directly aroused or suppressed by the
actions of our will the only directly
through the representation of things
which are usually joining with the
passions we wish to have and opposed to
the passions which we wish to reject so
well possible Stoics seem to allow for
passions to regulate other passions they
traditionally saw that something
inferior to virtue you know it's better
than not regulating your passions at all
but somehow it's lesser than virtue but
Descartes gives the example let's say
that you wanted to change your pupil
sighs that's not just something you can
change on command you can't say okay
people get smaller but a person can
change his or her pupil size indirectly
by fixing their gaze that of more
distant objects or by shining the light
into one's eye
so although likewise we can't simply
will a passion to cease we can make it
go away through focusing on a different
passion redirect which would result in
redirecting that animal spirits for him
so again if passions are merely physical
responses to external stimuli they don't
seem to be good or bad they just exist
and as a result of that rather than
seeing passions of the sickness of the
soul passions become another useful tool
of the body that like so many of the
things that we can do can be used for
good or evil
by reclassifying those passions from an
intellectual sickness to a physiological
event there is no longer a tension
between his physical account of the
passions and the stoicism that he wants
to follow because ultimately then the
passions are not caused by ignorance
instead they are simply responding as a
machine would respond to its environment
and although this can be done through
something external such as if you're
feeling sad you can put on Donald
College music to make you feel better
it's better done through one's own minds
so if you're feeling sad you can type
you're feeling angry for instance you
can maybe you think of something
melancholic to balance you out so sorry
I'm just
mm I okay I okay so the the passions are
something that's good they're even
pleasing to the soul they're useful when
they guided by reason and resolute
judgment are used to redirect these
harmful passions and so merely feeling
an initial passion such as anger revisit
blameworthy though giving in to those
and maybe striking someone would be or
allowing someone to be consumed by grief
would hinder his or her Trank ability
but the initial the initial passions are
just our body responding so since of all
passions by their nature are outside of
anyone's immediate control Descartes
believes a person must often use those
passions to counteract harmful ones and
in doing so he's able to maintain that
important aspect of stoic virtue that
it's rational while also maintaining
that there is no need to read oneself
passions because they're simply part of
our physiology so you say well he thinks
is able to reconcile all of these the
the physiological the new developments
in anatomy and physiology with the stoic
through the passions and he thinks that
just to connect the dots here when the
external goods since passions are plain
worthy it's possible to find enjoyment
in external goods so long as reasons
judging it's not harmful because again
external those are just stimuli
stimulating those physiological
responses so just to just to wrap things
up a little bit if we're trying to
understand stoicism in terms of
contemporary contemporary science seeing
our body it's in through contemporary
anatomy physiology
even though take arts physiology is
endearing to us today and even though
his physics turned out to be just wrong
he gives us a helpful model given this
physiological classification of the
passions
since there are amoral they're there in
themselves not blameworthy virtue
becomes something that we should pursue
because it's pleasurable and likewise
external Goods become beneficial they're
not necessary for the good life
and given that we tend to see bodies
material too late
materially today we may have a much more
advanced anatomy physiology but in a way
it's a card still sees our bodies
similarly and she shows us that we can
accept stoicism while creating a
platform for understanding the passions
in terms of contemporary science oh yeah
I don't have any trouble because I'm not
100% sure that des cartes passions the
word Zeki meaning would just felt like
his actions were overlapping you know I
mean this thing vid was complete when
you said passions with bait I was
referring to seemed to be more I think
the storage capacity you mean yeah it's
just filling you know so I did skip over
something just see that's where it's
physiology it's really weird
where you got the pineal gland like
whispering to the material soul and
clearly against you by the two noses or
got two nostrils two meters the pineal
gland has two things and then one thing
and there's only one soul so obviously
that's the condiment for talking to the
soul totally wrong where does yeah he
gives up this whole thing with pressure
going on and in a little area so he he
does need something broader than the
Stoics me and then the stoats me with
passions because he believes that they
need to come some from somewhere so he's
trying to draw the line between these
the interior our interior states our
ways of thinking and feeling and our our
body
so these these these passions that we
have maybe in the more it's doing sense
don't just arise from the flu they arise
from somewhere and he thinks that where
they rise from is going to be through
these external stimuli the Seneca you
know I think I remember right I don't
they can read sending of it I get this
race with my help me but I think that
you would agree that there's external
stimuli and then the initial passion
would arise call the caption but it's
when you go take it further you run with
it problem in creepiness natural it's
rescreen feel as a child lost wife right
but if you take that grief for them we
get in we've got three cannot last two
years three years origin then that's
what it's a problem all right thank you
right so where dick heart where Nick
heart would differ here is he would
think it's perfectly fine so for the
Stoics there are response would have to
be through a rational emotion right so I
stole my toe and I feel angry but I'm
not going to start swinging at people
because of practice stoicism for if I
were to use another passion to combat
that that would be somehow the baser or
lesser so if I'm feeling if I'm feeling
grief I should you I should combat that
with a rational emotion well Descartes
would be totally fine with you throwing
on some sad music to help you to arouse
a passion to counteract that because
they're not a sickness of the soul
they're just what our body does I'm
really not it call them boys I think
it's so going in first
yeah figuring that everybody up here
we've worked with Stoicism internet
figure they're like piloted it were
meeting every day do you see yourself
evolving you're thinking if some of
these questions were asked to do five or
ten years ago over five their chambers
of now I've been speaking about better
philosophy
[Music]
yeah absolutely
one thing I really like about stoicism
in it is it really challenges one to
continually self examine and recreate
might be two existential to say but
nonetheless of obviously use it to
revisit oneself and continue to grow
reframe how one sees the world based on
reflection and if one does that and see
that something will not only get better
at doing overtime but you learn as you
get older and so it's stoicism was
asking us really to fundamentally
reflect on the truth the world to change
ourselves and really should do that I
guess the question I have in relation
passionately you give me some examples
of actions that the cart was describing
my grief for lust what do you what are
those that you would say yeah that's a
passion that's imagine it would be
anything that so the word passion the
thing concerning the root word it's
something that's passive so it's not
something that you're doing to the world
so to speak it's something that's
happening to you or having responsive
things happening to you
so if grief in the sense of the passion
would be someone someone passive the way
that you care about and you're
experiencing this emotion as a result of
that thing prior to like in the stoic
view you'd have to reconsider it reframe
that through a rational emotion so with
rational emotions that would be
something that's active well the the
grieving over the bit
the deceased person would be passive and
so for Descartes he would be he's saying
that it's perfectly virtuous to helps us
to achieve that good life if we use one
passion to counteract another passion
because sometimes that's the only way to
help that passion you know someone
really really suffering from grief like
des cartes letter to awakens you know
just telling them you know be glad at
the time that you had her and celebrate
now that you're free to do other things
in that case reason sureness you know
what true but that's not gonna stop me
from grieving right the reason I ask
this is in the modern colloquial
definition of passion is usually
something I'm really into and want you
know but in that one that you're
describing it that's one of them right
yeah he would that he would categorize
that under desire I think
[Music]
yeah I think they're I think I think
that's right he's trying to first of all
explain how this could work given a
naturalistic account of the human body
and you know the human brain you know
the way he interpreted and worked out of
us was wrong but it certainly was move
in the direction that we're doing it
today so I think that's part of it but
then also by doing that recognizing that
the motions are something passions or
something that are just part of our
typical we are and completion we should
consider it something that's making us
less virtuous or something that's making
our lives somehow less good if we're if
we're using our reason to allow certain
passions to counteract other passions
okay
so I'm kind of do that it's Dawson I'm
just trying to understand so my
understanding so stoic would say that
anger is external passion but external
but passionate desires more internal
somehow anger is more
external desires internal and you got a
choice on some if they are passing and
everything external so for Descartes
everything would be it be about the
relation between the tubes so how how
one's body house ones machine responds
different different given it different
external inputs basically stories don't
really speak of abortions being
externally all internal one thing to
point out the Stoics across the board
all of them say anger is never good
resilience thinking the current things
that summing their kindred the Stoics
and it's no more external desire those
stories and and the thing that you're
talking about is the distinction between
someone that's aroused by passion and
and acting kind of without actually
looking into that feeling versus desire
is like you've done something bad
because you want to do so that's the
distinction kind of like between murder
and manslaughter stoic and storm where
there's a stoic he's in a bow there's
obviously other passengers and you know
it's a storm's blows up and everyone's
afraid and then they get too short they
get off the boat and the guy says oh you
throw straight in the storm he goes yeah
but I'm okay now
not worrying about it now because it
sounds like maybe take heart is maybe
looking at ways to distract yourself or
change your
emotional state using another emotion
where the Stoics talking about yeah
you'll have that initial emotional
response but then afterwards you realize
that that's passed and that's no longer
our control
now we're here now in this moment right
and you can sometimes bring it back down
and itself can be a challenge right so
getting off that boat you know I'm still
traveling and so that will help
counteracts how would you say take arts
conception here differs from escapism
like using a passion to have another
passion it's like different from like oh
I like fill the class and I'm gonna
binge watch Netflix for like five hours
how does he go about like actually the
dissolving rather than discovering it
yeah a lot of has to do an attention
this is the reason why even though he's
certainly taking liberties and molding
into its own thing why or one of the
reasons why he's still is in that camp
of neo stoic scent because it's if
you're just escaping then you're not
really doing it to help you find or live
the good life but if you are doing it to
help balance yourself out then so that
you can reduce that that harmful passion
then then that's okay so sue the
external viewer it might not be
distinguishable from subjective
perspective it would really just be
about what your intentions are so just
talk about what using one passion to
count reminds me of some of the research
I was into
attention and pain management and so
there are nowadays virtual reality to
give someone such a vivid presence and
experience that the idea is that there's
a finite amount of attention that we can
give to any one thing and so they good
use of having pain management just by
having someone experience some sort of
for the virtual reality experience let's
thank all of our speakers